the latest episode of succession had
fans of the hit HBO series in absolute
disarray and as Twitter chatter was
quick to point out there are still seven
episodes left in the show's final season
talk about a tough act to follow
spoilers ahead
as those who witnessed what is arguably
the biggest moment in television this
year already know Logan Roy the complex
father and CEO played by Brian Cox is
dead after surviving a brain hemorrhage
in the series premiered the Roy family
patriarch is finally gone for good
leaving the way star royco Empire in the
hands of a few less than loyal employees
his children on the other hand struggled
to hold themselves together at Conor's
wedding and fans couldn't help but
empathize with their loss as one fan on
Twitter put it Ken crying roam crying
shiv crying I'm crying you crying we
crying damn this season has been brutal
damn
oh man
he never even liked me though Logan's
actions would often border on
sadistically cruel his departure and the
moments surrounding it devastated
viewers one fan posted succession got me
wrecked right now and another concurred
writing this week's episode of
succession has destroyed me there was
also plenty of chatter on Twitter about
the superb acting showcase put on by
pretty much the entire cast one fan
posted I'm sobbing Sarah snook Jeremy
Strong and Kieran Culkin are second to
none they've all stepped it up in a huge
way give them Emmys that user wasn't the
only one that felt the impressive
Ensemble deserved gold statues for their
efforts with another fan posting
literally everyone in this succession
episode deserves an Emmy every single
performance is real and raw and
consistent with who these characters are
that is dead
another succession fan singled out
Kendall actor Jeremy Strong specifically
sharing stills of the actor crying in
the episode and tweeting give Jeremy
Strong the damn Emmy right now I love
you Dad
I do I love you strong won the Emmy for
Outstanding lead actor in a drama in
2020 for the season 2 finale this is not
for Tears he was nominated again in 2022
for season threes too much birthday
Sarah snook and Kieran Culkin were both
nominated twice for acting Emmys in 2020
and 2022 but both have yet to take home
a trophy Snook's performance this week
May finally earn her a win however as
she seems to be the clear standout among
fans online several fans agreed that her
reaction to Logan's death was by far the
most heartbreaking
I love you
uh
please not now
the episode resonated with viewers so
much due to the unexpected nature of
Logan's death after all for his many
faults fans weren't ready to say goodbye
to him either Logan Roy's death will go
down as a truly shocking moment in
television history as such it took a
moment for some succession fans to
accept that it actually happened one
Twitter user spent much of the episode
believing that it was all a ruse and
posted what does it say about Logan Roy
that for like 50 minutes I thought this
was some manipulative Ploy constructed
by him to outsmart his children another
fan echoed this view praising the
writers for keeping the audience in
suspense until more details came to
light posting that was a genius move by
the writers the audience was in essence
in the exact place the Roy children were
because we did not see the events of his
death so we were all experiencing the
same incredulity in fact the general
consensus among succession fans is that
this episode did a great job of putting
the audience in the Roy family's shoes
as one fan noted not showing Logan Roy's
Body for the first 45 minutes was
brilliant for leaving the audience in
denial just like Roman Roy I also wasn't
going to believe it until I saw it
foreign